Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Dans nos vies de mortels
qui s’agitent en tous sens,
on aspire souvent pour retrouver du sens
à revenir au calme,
à se mettre, comme on dit au vert.
Je pense que pour beaucoup d’entre vous,
cette photo illustre bien
l’idée qu’on se fait d’une nature
sereine, bienveillante,
où il fait bon se ressourcer assis
à l’ombre de ce vieux chêne si paisible.
Eh bien, aujourd’hui,
je viens faire tomber ce mythe.
Non, il n'y a rien de serein ou de calme
ou de paisible dans ce spectacle.
Moi, ce que je vois, ce n’est
pas un champ de pâquerettes,
c’est un champ de bataille.
C’est le théâtre d’une odyssée épique,
celle d’une armada de racines en guerre
contre le réchauffement climatique.
Mais c'est une odyssée dissimulée, cachée
à nous par l'insondable volonté des dieux.
Or, moi, c'est ma nature profonde.
J’ai toujours aimé ce qui était caché.
Je vous propose donc de soulever
ce joli tapis rouge
et de pénétrer avec moi
dans ce monde souterrain.
Ah oui, les muses qui m’ont coaché
pour cette présentation,
m’ont suggéré de ma focaliser
sur un ou deux points seulement,
histoire que le message passe.
Mais comme chacun sait qu’une bonne
odyssée ne démarre qu’à partir de trois,
j’ai donc choisi de vous chanter
trois arguments
pour vous convaincre
de l’importance des racines.
Premier argument de choc.
Nous sommes tous les enfants des racines.
Ou plutôt, nous ne serions
pas là sans elles.
Aucun animal terrestre, en fait, puisqu'à
peu près toute notre chaîne alimentaire
est basée au départ sur la production
de plantes terrestres.
Ben oui, même le plus carnivore
d’entre vous se rend bien compte
que sans ces herbes verdoyantes
qui ont permis de nourrir
nos grasses vaches du soleil,
impossible de se mettre
un bifteck sous la dent.
Or, les plantes qui pataugeaient
initialement dans l’eau,
n’ont pu coloniser le milieu terrestre
que grâce à cette innovation
technologique extraordinaire :
la racine.
C’est par la racine que les plantes
ont pu s’ancrer dans le sol
et récupérer ses ressources.
Car bien entendu,
le but premier d’une racine, c’est
de récupérer de l’eau et des minéraux
et de le donner à la plante.
Alors que les plantes aquatiques
peuvent se contenter
de puiser paresseusement dans l’eau
environnante leur petit souper,
les plantes terrestres, elles, ont dû
développer des armées de colonisatrices
pour récupérer le peu de ressources
accessibles dans le sol.
C'est là que notre odyssée démarre.
Les racines doivent progresser
dans un monde ténébreux, à tâtons,
contournant d’immenses obstacles,
naviguant d’un port du sol à l’autre
et affrontant maints périls.
Il leur faut souvent se battre,
déjà contre les racines d’autres plantes,
qui viendraient empiéter
sur leur territoire de pêche.
Et puis contre d'affreux
monstres souterrains.
Regardez, par exemple,
cette terrifiante créature
abominable, cyclopéenne : un nématode.
Véritable serpent de terre de plusieurs
dizaines de micromètres de longueur,
on le reconnaît facilement
à son allure filiforme,
la racine grecque du nématode
étant néma le fil.
Eh bien, croyez-moi que là-dessous,
la vie des racines ne tient
parfois qu’à ce fil.
Car si certains nématodes
sont à peu près sympa,
d’autres sont de véritables prédateurs
qui n’hésitent pas à dévorer les racines
et par là-même le revenu des agriculteurs.
Eh bien, croyez-moi,
notre ami Ulysse
n’aurait pas fait son petit malin
face à ce genre de monstre.
Eh bien les racines, tout comme Ulysse,
ne connaissent alors qu’une seule
stratégie : la fuite en avant.
Mais peut-être est-il temps
de le préciser :
les racines ne se déplacent pas
exactement comme nous.
Elles ont en fait une manière
bien particulière de se mouvoir,
qu’on pourrait qualifier de familiale.
Et c’est ce qui m’amène
à mon deuxième argument choc.
Un système racinaire,
c’est une famille modèle.
Mais une grande famille modèle, hein !
Au lieu de sept à la maison, on est
plutôt sur 7 millions à la maison.
Le principe de cette famille ?
Au bout de chaque racine,
se trouve un groupe de cellules
qui ne vieillissent jamais.
Les immortelles qui, ensemble, forment
une sorte de maman perpétuellement jeune,
belle et féconde.
Féconde, oui !
Oui, car chaque maman enfante en continu
des cellules filles derrière elle.
Or, les filles grandissent
et, ce faisant, traversent tous les affres
que nous connaissons nous aussi
dans notre âge d’or ingrat,
dont l’apparition de poils.
Eh oui, d’autres mythes tombent.
Les racines et puis les filles,
ont des poils.
On reviendra dans un instant
sur le rôle de ces poils.
En tout cas, c’est sur une véritable
saga familiale, matriarcale même,
qu’est basée la propulsion des racines.
Maman pousse d’un côté, mais de l’autre,
les cellules filles s’allongent
et ce faisant, pousse l’avant
de la racine, leur maman,
toujours plus loin dans le sol.
Et lorsqu’il est temps de penser
à la prochaine génération,
eh bien, certaines cellules filles
reçoivent le top départ
pour démarrer de nouvelles lignées
mère-filles, à bâbord ou à tribord,
formant ainsi
de nouvelles racines latérales.
Et donc, vous voyez que si la grand-mère,
à l’avant de la racine principale,
finissait, pour une raison ou pour
une autre, par perdre la tête,
eh bien,
la racine principale, cesserait d’avancer.
Mais rassurez-vous,
l’Olympe a bien fait les choses.
Pour compenser cette perte tragique,
ou alors pour fêter l’héritage en carbone
qui leur revient enfin,
les cellules filles les plus proches de
mémé font soudainement la bamboche
et deviennent elles-mêmes mamans, formant
ainsi de nouvelles racines latérales.
Donc, voyez, les racines,
c’est un peu comme une hydre.
On coupe une tête ici, mais il en repousse
deux autres juste au-dessus.
Mais ce que je trouve le plus inspirant
dans tout ça,
c’est que malgré cette distance
intergénérationnelle croissante,
malgré l’éloignement de toutes ces mères
et grands-mères navigant vaillamment,
seules à la proue du navire,
toutes restent connectées entre elles
via ce super réseau familial
qui leur permet de s’échanger
des informations, des recettes de cuisine
ou des ressources.
Ah ! Eh bien, intéressons-nous donc
enfin à cet échange de ressources.
On l’a vu, la mission principale
d’une racine est de ravitailler la plante
en eau et en minéraux.
Mais où trouver ces ressources cachées,
en particulier cet azote, ce phosphore
qui se font si rares dans le sol ?
Eh bien, les racines semblent
s’en remettre à la bonne fortune.
Ou alors, pour certaines, à une sorte
de mystérieux chant des sirènes
qui les attire mystérieusement
vers les ressources en question.
Pour être tout à fait franc,
on ne sait pas très bien
comment ça marche.
Mais quand une racine arrive dans une zone
où les ressources semblent abondantes,
elle peut lancer ses filles
à la conquête du territoire
et installer un comptoir pour commercer
avec les autochtones.
C’est que les racines
ne font pas que prendre,
elles donnent aussi, et c’est ce qui
m’amène à mon dernier argument,
l’argument choc de titans,
celui qui m’intéresse le plus
dans mes travaux de recherche.
Les racines se nourrissent du sol,
mais le sol se nourrit aussi des racines.
Je m'explique.
Tout autour des racines,
vivent de nombreuses communautés
de petits organismes du sol.
Certains ne sont pas très gentils,
on l’a vu auparavant.
Mais d’autres sont très bénéfiques
pour la plante,
en particulier certaines
bactéries et certains champignons.
En fait, c’est cette société cosmopolite
de micro-organismes du sol
qui va récupérer la plupart
des minéraux précieux
extraits à la sueur de leurs enzymes
et les donner à la plante.
Au passage, c’est justement
via les poils racinaires
qu’une bonne partie
de ces échanges se réalise.
Mais alors que reçoivent les
micro-organismes du sol en échange
de leurs bons et loyaux services ?
Eh bien, leurs récompenses, ce sont
des substances produites par la plante
et dont ces petites bêtes raffolent,
notamment des susucres.
Eh bien, c'est là que notre odyssée
devient planétaire.
Ça vous paraît obscur ?
Bon, remontons à la lumière,
on y verra mieux :
en haut, grâce à la photosynthèse,
les feuilles vertes récupèrent du carbone
sous forme de CO2 dans l’atmosphère
et le transforment en sucre.
Ce sucre est ensuite acheminé
vers les racines pour les faire pousser,
mais aussi pour servir de monnaie
d’échange dans le grand marché souterrain.
Et en troquant ces marchandises,
les racines deviennent des véritables
passeurs du monde souterrain,
car une fois digérée par
ces micro-organismes du sol,
une partie du carbone contenu
dans ces sucres
reste durablement piégée dans le sol.
Vous saisissez maintenant ?
Les racines sont
non seulement nos ancêtres,
de vaillantes mères
qui naviguent en solidaire,
mais elles sont aussi nos alliées
dans la guerre contre
le réchauffement climatique.
Car en transférant inlassablement
du carbone depuis l’atmosphère
vers les tréfonds du sol,
les racines nous permettent
de compenser une partie du CO2
que nous, arrogants mortels, continuons
d’émettre vers le ciel
en brûlant insensément
ce beau carbone fossile
que la nature avait si sagement enfoui
à vingt mille lieues sous l’Atlantide.
Alors oui, je sais, certains d’entre vous
diront que je suis un petit peu mytho
et c’est vrai, j’ai un petit
peu forcé le trait.
Tout n’est pas toujours
aussi noir et rouge,
mais c’est bien pour ça
qu’on fait des recherches.
Pour mieux comprendre comment
tout ce bazar souterrain fonctionne
Et moi, les racines, c’est vraiment le
genre de solutions low-tech, bas carbone,
sur lesquelles j’ai envie de miser,
plutôt qu’un énième véhicule hybride
ou une autre chimère.
L’ironie de l’histoire,
c’est que dans notre agriculture,
on a longtemps sélectionné des plantes
qui n’investissaient que très peu
dans ce commerce souterrain.
On a privilégié des blés à gros grains
pour notre assiette,
mais à tout petit gain pour la planète.
Alors aujourd’hui, on tente
de redresser la barre
et de voir ce qui pourrait se passer
si on libérait vraiment tout
le potentiel des racines.
Et moi, je vais jusqu’à essayer
de simuler tout ça
sur mon petit écran d’ordinateur.
Regardons ce que ça donne...
Ah !
C’est beau comme l’antique, non ?
Ce qui est chouette, c’est que je peux
m’amuser à tisser et retisser
mon réseau racinaire,
un peu comme ma peau de Pénélope,
juste pour voir ce qui se passe.
On a d’ailleurs un peu tendance
à se prendre pour un dieu en faisant ça.
On change une règle universelle,
on clique sur un bouton
et on regarde ce qui se passe.
Tiens, aujourd’hui, Poséidon a dit
que les racines ne pouvaient plus tourner
que dans un seul sens,
disons vers tribord.
Eh bien voilà nos racines prises
dans des tourbillons infernaux.
Bon, je sais, on n'est pas
là pour prendre racine.
En tout cas, la prochaine fois que vous
serez assis sous ce vieux chêne,
au lieu de vous extasier devant ces jolies
feuilles vertes comme des Lotophages,
j’espère que vous saurez, vous aussi,
chanter cette odyssée autour de vous
et rendrez hommage
à ces millions d’héroïnes
qui continuent à agir pour nous,
en secret,
sous nos pieds.
Merci à vous.
(Applaudissements)